so our left off we were just essentially
chugging through this fairly hairy
derivative this definite integral this
antiderivative it takes my brain a
little while to come up with the next
term so we evaluated at two and now we
have to subtract this evaluated at 1 so
minus 16 pi minus 4 PI over 3 oh sorry
plus the minus is going to be on on
everything
oh no sorry that is a minus that's a
minus plus 4 pi right because X is 1
minus PI over 2 and now we can simplify
it let's see what we can do this is
really a hairy problem so let's see the
16 PI minus 8 pi that equals 8 pi and
then that's a plus so 32 plus 8 PI 32 PI
plus 85 that equals 40 pi so let's see
I've simplified it to 40 pi and what's
minus 8 times 4 is 32 PI over 3 minus 32
PI over 3 and then all of that let's see
if I can simplify this let's see 16 PI
plus 4 PI that's 20 PI just 20 PI and
then let's see minus 4 PI over 3 minus
PI over 2 so let's call it get a common
denominator for this this part right
here so if I put everything over 6 20 PI
over 6 is the same thing as 120 PI over
6 and then minus 4 PI over 3 if I put it
over 6 it becomes 8 PI over 6
all right and then PI over 2 if I put it
over 6 it becomes 3 PI over 6 so minus 3
PI so this whole term that we're going
to subtract from this term is equal to
120 minus 11 right so that's 109 PI over
6
this equals 1 is that right yeah 109 PI
over 6
see what happens when you make up
problems on the fly you get
ugly numbers 109 PI over six and what is
what is that top part translate so this
is what we're going to subtract this is
when we evaluate the the antiderivative
at one let's simplify this one so that
one if we put three common denominator
that's 120 pi over three minus 32 PI
over three 120 minus 32 let's see we get
90 88 right 88 PI over three so that
equals 88 PI over three that remember
that's just for the top part and then
this is more of a review of fractions
than anything else and then if I want to
put it over six I just double it right
so I think we're almost done let me
switch colors so if we go over a
denominator of six eighty eight PI over
three let's see if I double that I get
one sixty one seventy six right one
seventy six pi minus this minus 109 pi
I'm sure I made a careless mistake these
are these are my least favorite type of
things to do hairy fractions so 176
minus 109 that's the same thing as 76
minus nine and that is 65 so our final
answer is 65 PI over 6 which isn't as
hairy as it seemed when we started the
problem but that's pretty neat this is
kind of a strange shape it's it's kind
of a wide ring that has that has the
upper part of the ring and the inner
part of the ring are hard edges but then
it's curved on the outside and we were
able to figure out the volume of that
especially then what was weird about
this is when it was rotated around the
line y is equal to minus 2 hopefully I
didn't confuse you these are about as
difficult as these you know volume of
revolution problems get if you if you
want it more just let me know I will see
you in the next video